mind your decisions I'm presto occur in
quadrilateral ABCD sights ad and BC have
the same length angle A plus angle B is
equal to 90 degrees if a B is equal to
20 and C D is equal to 10 what is the
area of the quadrilateral ABCD I think
Cree then for the suggestion for a
little bit of a challenge you can solve
the general case where a B has a length
equal to X and C D has a length equal to
Y a version of this problem was given to
class 8 students in India who were
approximately 13 years old pause the
video if you'd like to give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
we can solve this problem with a clever
trick of thinking inside the box we will
make three copies of this quadrilateral
we will rotate each shape at 90 degree
increments and overlap the two sides
that are equal to each other in the end
we will construct a new quadrilateral
what can we say about this shape well
each side length will be equal to X and
since angle A plus angle B is equal to
90 degrees the entire shape will be a
square therefore its area will be equal
to x squared there's another way that we
can compute the area of this large shape
it'll be equal to four times the area of
the quadrilateral plus the area of this
quadrilateral on the inside what can we
say about this quadrilateral now each
side length will be equal to Y and since
we rotated the quadrilateral 90 degrees
each time each of these sides will be at
a 90-degree angle to each other
therefore this shape is also a square
and its area will be equal to Y squared
so we have four times the area of the
quadrilateral plus y squared is equal to
x squared we can simplify this formula
and we can get the area of the
quadrilateral is equal to x squared
minus y squared all over 4
we can then substitute in particular
values and solve the original problem
that the area of the quadrilateral is
equal to 75 but the beauty of this
method is that we've solved the general
case for x and y we does have a simple
formula that the area of this
quadrilateral is equal to x squared
minus y squared all over 4 and it's a
beautiful construction that turns this
mysterious problem into a very simple
formula just by putting the jigsaw
pieces in the right place
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on YouTube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]